so thanks very much to the organizers
for inviting me this is actually my
first official visit to simons so it's
it's very nice although I do still get
stuck in the stairwell after 5pm each
day but I need to go to the Student
Center and ok alright so this is joint
work with Tom and you may know that in
sometimes the most classic model in
physics for which Monte Carlo algorithms
were developed is not the Ising model
and not graph coloring it's the hard
disk model so here's this 1953 paper
which you know metropolis at all four
out of five of the authors were two
married couples and so here they used
one of the early electronic computers
the maniac to study the hard disk model
and more generally they looked at
interacting particles in two and three
dimensions with various kinds of
potentials or forces between them but so
they did these numerical calculations
with N equals 224 and so at the time
this was impressive and they used a
local markov chain where you would grab
a random disk and come up with some
random displacement for it but I you
know nearby and then if moving it by
that amount would cause it to overlap
another disk you reject the move and do
nothing in otherwise you do the move all
right so they did this to understand the
equation of state sort of how the
pressure varies with the density and so
on um so here's the notation we're going
to use we have n disks in the unit
square it will have cyclic boundary
conditions so it's the unit Taurus which
means each one has radius 1 over root n
on time some constant and i'll use Rho
the density to mean the total area
covered by all the disks so the area of
each one 4 PI R squared times N and so
the disk may not overlap so the Centers
of two discs may not be within a
distance to our so we think we think of
each disk it's a radius R but it's
surrounded by kind of danger zone of
radius 2 are in
the center of other discs may not be now
for independent sets on graphs the
discrete version of this problem it
seems to be more popular in the
literature to consider the model where
the number of discs varies and we wait
configurations by lambda to the end for
some fugacities lambda and that is also
a very worthy model and as you may know
physicists call that the grand canonical
ensemble but for us the the number of
discs and the density will be fixed so
yes my Odysseus is to the pilots man oh
yeah you're right I'm sorry I made these
slides late last night yes sorry the
total area of the danger zones will be
at most this by the Union bound but yes
that force of course they can cross i'm
giving away everything now all right
okay thanks good okay good thank any
questions all right all right so before
we try to prove things let's find out
what the truth is and there's an amazing
amount of phenomenology in the system so
of course when the when the density is
at a certain amount the density of a
close packing of disks then the only
available state is a triangular close
packing and here's the three-dimensional
version of that courtesy of Tom and
varsha's daughter shreya but then at a
density around point 7 there is a phase
transition from a kind of liquid or
gaseous state where everything has a lot
of room to move to a state which is
called a solid although in fact what we
mean by solid in the continuous setting
in two dimensions turns out to be very
quite subtle so there are actually two
different types of order we could
imagine one is positional order what you
imagine in a crystal where there's some
periodicity to the positions of the
discs there is a more subtle kind of
order orientational order we're on the
the angle between two neighboring
far away is correlated with the angle
between two neighboring discs here and
you might think these are the same but
so first of all in two dimensions
there's this classic thing called the
perils argument that says that we can't
actually have correlations that don't
decay at all with long distance they
have to decay at least polynomial E and
so in the liquid or gaseous phase they
decay exponentially there is also
experimentally a very narrow range of
densities with a fascinating thing
called the heck static phase where the
positional correlations decay
exponentially but the orientational
correlations decay only polynomial e so
what this means is that if I tell you
that there's a disk here it doesn't tell
you much at all about the position of a
disc here and yet if I tell you that
this disc has a neighbor at this angle
it does make it more likely that this
disc has a neighbor that angle so you
know this is this was conjectured on
physical grounds a while ago and it was
only recently with the help of new
Markov chains which are not the ones
were studying that there was convincing
numerical evidence for this so there are
these little arrows here describing the
the orientation you know of course there
are six different directions you could
take typically to one of your six
nearest neighbors but this blue area
here is a whole bunch of the world that
has roughly the same orientational order
and there's even this coexistence
between ordered and disordered areas
here's some more even more recent
numerical experiments this is with a
million discs by the way and these
stripes here are where there are
positional correlations because things
are kind of roughly stacked with the
same orientation so it's a very
fascinating system there's much more
going on it seems than just liquid
versus solid or gaseous versus solid in
any case we're going to do something
infinitely more modest today on which is
studying a particular Markov chain so
here at each step we choose a uniformly
random disk from the n disks we choose a
uniformly random position in
entire world and we attempt to move it
there and we do so unless it caused it
unless doing that would cause it to
overlap another disk so we'd like to
know when this mix is rapidly so I'm
going to start by reviewing this result
of Canon Mahoney and montenegro that it
mixes rapidly up to one-eighth so order
n log n time for Rho less than
one-eighth they also proved polynomial
time for Rho equals 1 8th on our result
is up 2.15 for which compared to a point
125 is not an amazing improvement
especially given that the truth is point
seven but I help you like the techniques
and yeah I hope you like the techniques
we will also show kind of mostly we're
still working on it this is a workshop
this is you know so you know come on so
welcome to my workshop the tools are
still scattered all over the table we
think we can prove spatial mixing up to
that same density although I will try to
convince you that the connection between
optimal temporal mixing and spatial
mixing is slightly harder to establish
in this case than it is in cases you may
be familiar with all right so lots of
our speakers have already reminded us of
path coupling so we define a
neighborhood relationship between two
states in our case that will be if they
disagree on the position of a single
disc and then we if we define symmetric
then you know bubbly and dire tell us
that if on every path of a shortest path
through the state space the expected
distance contracts multiplicatively in
expectation then so does the total
distance and then we would get n log n
mixing time ok so here's what these
folks did on they say ok so suppose you
disagree on the location of a single
disc that'll be the I fdisk so X I and
why I are different x j equals YJ for
all other j so we choose a random disc j
and a location Z and usually we try to
move both disks to that location but if
that location is in the danger zone of
either disks then we try to move
XJ to that location but we try to move
YJ to its mirror image reflected around
this line bisecting the line between x
and y so this is a lot like jarom's
trick for glabra dynamics in graph
coloring where you swap the two
forbidden colors and the point is we
want to correlate the events that these
that these moves succeed or fail so this
way for instance if I try to move X here
and it would overlap if I try to move XJ
here and it would overlap with X I then
that same move here will the move will
fail in the Y chain is well because it
will overlap with why I am already so so
what can happen well there are good
moves and bad moves remember this is the
only disagreement between these two so
if we succeed in moving them both to the
same location than the disagreement
disappears and the distance decreases by
1 and the probability of that is 1 over
n the probability that we choose to move
the I fdisk times the total area of the
available space so the fraction of the
world where we can move a disk which is
one minus the union of all the danger
zones so here we're going to use there's
the four was that that's where it was
supposed to be it escaped um so by the
Union bound that air that fraction of
the world is at least 1 minus 4 times
the density you see that right yes what
do you mean by move if you have you need
a pastor in between oh no you pick it up
and put it down over there right right
yes okay yeah I mean I'm so again the
original Markov chain that people used
in 1953 did local moves so you can
imagine bad initial conditions where a
lot of the disks are clustered in one
corner of the world and then the local
move would maybe take quite a while
presumably polynomial time for things to
diffuse out of there whereas this global
move dynamics might
by teleporting things might mix more
quickly okay so that's a lower bound on
the probability of a good move then a
bad move is where we take a disc that we
already agreed on before and we succeed
in one or both chains moving it here or
leaving it there or moving it here or
leaving it there so that now we have a
disagreement on the j DH discs as well
the probability of that is at most the
area of wise danger zone because again
if we try to tell if we try to move X
into X is danger zone and y into the
mirror image both moves will fail ok so
again as in as in a jarom's trick we
only you know if we hadn't thought of
this mirror image thing there'd be a
factor of two here because both danger
zones would be dangerous to us ok we
beings I all right so when we combine
this we get that the expected distance
decreases as long as a row is less than
one-eighth good alrighty so what are the
ingredients you know stepping back
viewing this field somewhat from the
outside how do we make these things fly
so on in this case we used a very simple
Markov chain this global move dynamics
is clearly very simple we were a bit
clever about the coupling on just as in
that classic coupling for glob or
dynamics but of course there are other
things you can do you can try to be more
clever with the chains so in the world
of independent sets on graphs for
instance Dyer and green hill and i guess
and libyan Vigoda i considered moves an
expanded markov chain where in addition
to adding and removing things from the
independent set you also try sliding
things to their neighbors and then you
can get an improvement in the critical
fugacities engrain at which you do those
slide moves um but you can also be
clever with the metrics so there's a
paper by Eric where he gets the the same
improvement on but with the simple
original Markov chain but changing the
metric instead
dang that well let's if two states have
a disagreement but most of the ways for
them to gain a new disagreement are
blocked by neighbors farther away well
then they're less likely to move farther
away so morally they seem closer
together so let's count them as closer
together so then there's a coefficient
that you optimize there in that metric
and you get the same improvement so
there seems to be some kind of trade-off
here between being clever with the chain
versus cleverer with the metric and that
was part of our motivation our other
motivation of course is that may be
because computer science has this this
odd focus on discrete valued things i'm
not sure why something to do with the
nature of electronics there has been
relatively little work on continuous
valued stay spaces an important
exception is by Dana and Peter Winkler
where they looked at moving points
around on an interval or on a circle
which is in a sense the one dimensional
version of this problem okay good so
here's what we're going to do it seems
that if if two states disagree in the
location of a single disk if they don't
disagree very much of those disks are
almost in the same place that should
count for less rather than just saying
oh it's hamming distance it counts for
one whenever they disagree even a little
so we're going to define the the
difference as some function little D of
the distance between X I and why I the
two positions if they're really far
apart so that their danger zones don't
even overlap will say that that's one
but then we'll have that function go
continuously 20 as the distance goes
down to 0 so our goal is then to find
the function that contract in the in
this coupling or that we can prove
contracts for the largest possible
density on you know if you like you can
think of this sort of this earth mover
distance so if you took something linear
in L that might already give you some
improvement but we're going to look for
arbitrary nonlinear functions and by the
way you might be thinking to yourself
well ok
they're going to show that this
continuous distance decreases
exponentially over time in expectation
but how do we know that the two states
really coincide so here we'll borrow
this argument from Randall and winkler
the point is that if in my two states
the this continuous metric is very small
between them so that all of the disks
are very close to each other in the two
states well that means that almost all
moves now will either succeed in both or
fail in both so with an additional n log
n steps for coupon collecting we will
have all the disks in literally the same
places ok so it's a kind of two-phase
argument good question so um we are
actually mixing uh our state spaces
actually labeled disk arrangements so
the disks have are ordered with indices
one through n so you're right what if in
X this is called disc one and that's
called just two and in why that's
reversed we will use that idea on by
changing the indices when it whenever
it's convenient to us so we're not going
to do something sophisticated like find
the minimum matching but we'll do
something kind of greedy so suppose this
was my previous disagreement and I've
just created a new disagreement by
succeeding to move this disk in one
train and not the other for instance
well now if the cost of these two edges
is less than the cost of these two edges
then I should switch which one I call X
I and which one I call XJ so arm here's
the special effect and in particular you
know a lot of the time YJ will be quite
far away so that these distances will be
one anyway and so I'll up or down this
process by simply asking is this closer
to this than this is ok so I'll switch
whenever that whenever that's the case
alright so putting this all together um
this is going faster than I thought it
would i if I end early I think you'll
probably forgive me um okay so now we
have to do some geometry so but you
already know the idea so now it's just
some geometry so um I'll use L for the
distance between the two disks of the
original disagreement I'll use I'll
suppose that something succeeds in Y and
fails and X these are the the danger
zones and then I'll say that I'll use s
for the distance between y and this new
location Z so what's the expected change
in the distance well so by the way this
is called the danger Crescent it's wise
danger zone minus X is danger zone and
it's area that little latex symbol is an
upper bound on the probability of a bad
move okay because a bad move can only
happen if the chosen Ozzy is in that
Crescent so you know again Kenan Mahoney
and montenegro said well that's you know
less than or equal to the area of a disk
of radius 2 are but we're saying well if
they're close together then it's much
less than that all right so here is the
expected change in the distance um so
this is the cost of the previous
disagreement and again if a good move
occurs that that distance disappears so
by the Union bound the probability of a
good move is still at least 1 minus 4
row we did not play with that term we
would like to now what about the
probability of a bad move well that's
this the area of this danger crescent
and we pessimistically assume that that
will create something of cost one unless
this distance s is less than this
distance L so we integrate s from 0 to l
this theta here tell
Elle's us the size of that arc that we
can integrate around and then if s is
less than L we swap so we get rid of the
cost DL and we pay for this edge instead
so the savings is d of l minus D of s
okay so yes yes we're still right so
does not have the usual lower bound in
the path coupling theorem that says you
know the cost of each edge is at least
one right that's why right so if you
follow the proof of the path coupling
theorem right what you learn is that
this continuous metric gets very small
and then we're using this argument from
Randall and winkler that says once this
continuous metric is really small right
then the symmetric differences of all
these danger zones are so small so the
next n log n moves where the next n log
n successful moves will cause all of the
disagreements to disappear completely
and that formula is the change in the
distance that you've got there I think
yes this is the change in this
continuous metric yeah but here you're
assuming all these are exactly the same
well we're okay so we are doing path
couplings so the previous x and y
disagreed only at a single disc right
but if for that pair we do you know we
have this mirror image coupling and then
if we do a move and we go from one
disagreement 22 well the cost will be
the cost of that new disagreement it's
you know if you if you start I mean
because this move because this dynamics
is global typically the disc you are
trying to move is very far away if you
succeed in both cases then it might be
rather close to x and y but we
pessimistically assume that we succeed
in one case and not the other so this
disagreement here has cost one because
this distance is very large it's much
larger than the radii of the discs and
even if we swap this one would be of
course should I go back to the figure
so for french military integrations you
the minute of a old pass my
configuration to the other change one is
good but it's okay to discontinue I mean
in other I I the continuous metric which
is the shortest path distance defined in
state space the minimum over all paths
of the sum of the continuous costs of
each disagreement okay so first I'm
going to show that I mean you know
triangle inequality and linearity of
expectation if all of those things are
decreasing and expectations so is the
sum let me interpret his way I think so
in the usual path covering automatic you
say that if you couple adjacent things
which are a distance one that's good
enough because you can somehow many
things right hey what if several pairs
different more than one bed it works two
pairs of x and y different but your
distance metric is small enough that the
sum of the difference is less than one
isn't that a more basic case undivided
induction audiometric which is
continuous well but I am I am only
thinking I mean this equation I i am
assuming that these two states had one
disagreement before they there was one
disc which is in different places in x
and y totally lesson one the only reason
you had that lower bound of one before
is because you want to fly bar cars in
topology say when it's smaller than
water but now he thought doesn't do that
it gets the distance down down down and
then when it's that's smaller than n
squared then e 1 over N squared right
but why couldn't it be the toothpaste if
during the continuous wise it would be
that that would improve the argument I
mean I mean you're you know you're right
that I mean you're right that the
shortest path of single disagreements
charging me for each disagreement well
let's see I mean
you're right that that might be a bit
bigger than the minimum matching but III
but it's hard for me to think about
pairs of things that disagree in more
than one places in more than one on more
than one disk because then I can't use
this mirror image coupling let me near
erigeron what this distance is also the
robot so this guy's different into
confusion so it's 0.02 you do the
coupling that this 0.01 goes in
expectation to another opinion and this
view point zero one goes expectation
pond over the video then you can couple
everything so together it's to other
video alright so it's the same argument
that you have inside the past coupling
you know just using the fact that you
can break you know your understanding
inequality once you have to differences
in distance that was the sound one
difference plus the other we have plenty
of time any other objections okay all
right yeah ok so again this this bound
is pessimistic in a couple of ways but
it is an upper bound all right so this
will be contracting so you know this
change will be minus some positive
constant alpha over n times the previous
distance if you know flipping things
around this inequality holds but now
look this is you know a linear
constraint on the function diavel at
various places so it's a linear program
so now we can do things like let's again
diavel is one whenever L is bigger than
four times the radius because the danger
zones don't overlap so we assume that
those kind of distant those distant
differences those large differences all
cost us one on and so then we could for
instance divide the interval from 0 to 4
r into a bunch of subintervals and
consider well what if diavel was
constant ins each subinterval and solve
this linear program and then we'll just
look for the largest row for which the
resulting linear program is feasible but
we we
that little did um yeah we didn't we you
know because that comes for free because
you I mean why does that come for free
we didn't actually impose those
constraints separately I remember having
a conversation about this two years ago
um and no we don't impose that it's sub
additive or why does it come for free I
guess we between two configurations we
always interpolate by a path of things
which just disagree at a single disc
probe steps has to be the Hamming
distance so so that I mean it's an upper
bound I guess the point is that if it
was if the function was super additive
then you would get a smaller distance by
moving the disc a little bit and then
moving it a bit more as opposed to doing
the it in one step but so as an upper
bound I think everything's okay and
you'll see in a moment that well here's
the function we get on the little
zigzags here are two pixels wide so here
we divided this interval into 256 sub
intervals and as we divide it into more
sub intervals we got slightly better
lower bounds on row and it looks as if
we're not going to do any better and of
course I can't tell you anything about
whether this is actually converging to
anything maybe you can but so this is
our metric um it's kind of nice looking
you know the other thing we tried before
solving this linear program was just
trying various analytic forms and
varying their parameters but none of
them did quite as well as this and we
don't know analytically what shape this
ought to be from that previous integral
equation except in the interval from 0
up to our it looks like a straight line
but it's not quite it's it's this
function and you can work it out here
because
if if x and y are already so close that
the distance between them is less than R
since this new position is it has to be
at least are from why you'll never swap
so in this case the the swap term just
disappears and you can just work it out
interestingly enough and this is just a
numerical result the constraints up to
here are tight and the constraints
beyond there seem to be slack I don't
know what that means probably it means
there's something clever we could do all
right so point 154 woohoo all right so
how could we improve this well the you
know the the thing most crying out for
improvement is this incredibly
pessimistic lower bound on the
probability of a good move so again this
for row is an upper bound the Union
bound on the union of all the danger
zones and of course you know in any
reasonable configuration the danger
zones overlap a lot in fact when you if
you're more than one quarter of the
close packing density they have to
overlap right does that make sense
because otherwise you know right so um
but so there's kind of a basic problem
here which I think we should all I
struggle with a little bit so you know
what do you want to do you want to say
oh I'm going to couple with the
stationary distribution or I'm going to
do some kind of warm starts so that I'm
coupling with things where the danger
zones overlap a lot but this is a path
coupling argument and the problem is
that even if I'm trying to couple this
state with a state run from the
stationary distribution where there's
lots of overlap I need to think about
this path through state space of
individual changes and it's not clear
what I can say about the intermediate
states along this path ok so the
overarching concern here
which we should all discuss is how can
we do path coupling in a less
adversarial way can we get any of the
warmth of a warm start into the states
along the path in a path coupling
argument um good yes that's what I just
said okay so now let's talk a little bit
about spacial mixing so um as many of
you know ah well see okay good so if we
we sent this to a physics journal the
journal of statistical physics which
publishes lots of rigorous work in
mathematical physics and the referee
report said we don't care about this
mixing time stuff I mean you know don't
tell us you have a good algorithm for
sampling we have really good algorithms
for sampling ah but if you could tell us
something about spatial mixing that
would be great so okay because then from
from their point of view then you would
really have a lower bound on the
critical density for the appearance of
the solid or even the heck static phase
so what they want to know is that all
kinds of correlations positional
orientational anything decay
exponentially so as many of you know
there's a long history in mathematical
physics of showing that temporal mixing
the sort of optimal temporal mixing
order n log n implies spatial mixing and
there's this nice paper that takes this
as they call it a combinatorial view
Dyer Sinclair Vigoda and whites which
proves this by counting disagreements
these are more functional analysis
flavored results that I don't fully
understand this paper i really liked
because i finally understood what was
going on and so the argument is simply
that if you mix really quick clip
quickly there just isn't time for
information to get from the boundary
condition deep inside the system so we
want to adapt this argument it's
slightly tricky because our state space
is continuous although that turns out
not to be that big a deal um you know
you might briefly worry that there's
uncountably many paths by which
information could spread on the
bigger issue is that our markov chain is
non-local so you know if i try to move
this disk over there and there's a
disagreement here and i succeed in one
case and not on the other suddenly i
have a disagreement all the way over
here so it will back teleport all the
way across the system so we think we can
handle this so first of all to handle
the continuity we simply divide the
world into blocks of with two are and
then if you think about it for a moment
you'll see that information can only get
from each block to the eight neighboring
blocks the King's move blocks on that
sort of discrete eise's the the path by
which things can travel and but then
there are these teleportations so the
saving grace of the teleportations is
that the probability that i choose this
disk to try to move and that i happen to
try to move it to that location thus
creating a disagreement over here is
order 1 over n squared whereas the local
things move with probability 1 over n
because i have to choose this particular
area to try to move into so we need to
do some counting where we have these
disagreement paths that include these
jumps so um we can consider different
boundary conditions of course but one
kind of boundary condition we want is
suppose that in the in the wise state in
addition to all the other end disks
there's also a fixed disk at the origin
okay or maybe a pair at some orientation
which is going to try to impose their
order on the rest of the world so as in
the dire at all paper if we want to
bound correlations at a given distance D
will imagine running the Markov chain
for time proportional to DN for some
constant and then we'll use this
triangle inequality so the equilibrium
distance added the the you know and I
didn't I didn't add all the stuff given
the boundary and in the patch and I
I can only handle so many subscripts and
superscripts but so we want to know that
these two equilibrium distributions are
close and so we do that by saying well
if T is large enough to mix fairly well
then the equilibrium distribution and X
will be close to what we get an X after
tea steps the same is true for y so then
we just need to bound the distance
between x and y after T steps which is
the probability on which is the
probability that a disagreement manages
to spread from the origin to that patch
so there is a lemma here that we need to
prove which is that the total variation
distance in a patch decreases
exponentially we think we can do that ok
so then we just have to do a little
combinatorics and I'm almost done so
this is just like in dire Sinclair
Vigoda and whites this is the Union
bound over all these local paths and i'm
not sure if you really want to see it
but it's a fun thing to do so if you're
going to move a disagreement just
locally then in order to get it distance
d blocks away the path has to take at
least m of this m steps for emma's at
least d on we sum over all the tuples of
times at which those steps could occur
this is an upper bound on the number of
those paths remember we spreaded each
step to one of our eight neighboring
blocks and this is a probability with
constants hidden that that path would
occur and then you get you you get used
this upper bound and get a geometric
series and it's exponentially small
indie because we have to take at least d
steps so this is nice this is what we
want right so we want this probability
to be exponentially small indie so that
correlations a distance d away decay
exponentially in d all right well then
there are these paths with jumps um so
there's one piece of good news about the
paths with jumps
so you might think that okay every local
step I get a factor of eight because I
can move in those eight directions so if
m is the number of local steps i would
have eight to the M and you might think
that if there are J a teleportation
steps since those can go anywhere you
might think i would have J to the N the
good news is I have to end up in a
particular place okay and in order to
end up in that particular place my last
jump for a given a terminal local path
has to have been to a particular place
so it's actually J to the N minus 1
head to the j minus one thank you okay
in that case the slide was correct so uh
we do you know we just do some simple
bounds what we get is this factor 1 over
N times something which alarmingly is
growing exponentially with d um that's a
little nerve-wracking but it's only
because we let the time grow with d and
because we're doing a very naive
argument where disagreements just spread
we don't take into account the fact that
there is a coupling and the
disagreements also disappear at a
certain rate so fine we can cut off this
exponential growth by saying don't have
t continue growing with d have it grow
up to a certain point and then what we
get is that this total variation
distance goes down as exponentially in d
with a floor which is a bit bigger than
1 over n is that really there or is that
a fault of our analysis so in particular
this means that we're only establishing
exponential decay out to distances of
about login and beyond that we're saying
that there's this one over N floor in
the difference but actually this makes
sense because how did I tell you these
two states differ I told you that in the
Y state in addition to all the other
disks I have a disk or maybe two disks
at the origin so now there's just less
room for all the others to move around
in there's a little bit more pressure on
them and so we think it's reasonable to
say that if the boundary conditions
differ in the remaining volume that
there would be this floor so this is all
the number of disks
no n is going to infinity I mean I mean
so the way we've defined things is that
the world is the unit Taurus and n is
increasing and the disks are getting
smaller so we're packing more and more
of them in but this the little boundary
condition in the origin is also getting
smaller does that make sense yeah can
you fix it by having two different
boundary conditions only allowed to have
to have the same number of so we were
arguing about this right so right so for
instance what if in both cases there's
there's a pair of disks but there it's
just their orientation changes this is a
matter of some controversy in the
co-authorship team on this paper so yeah
so I mean this analysis would have the
same problem but in that case we're not
sure about that all right so I just want
to end by saying what we all ought to be
working on instead instead of this
single move single disc dynamics and
some of you know about this in fact I
think I first heard about this from from
Dana and then there was this nice thing
at the aspen center of physics where Tom
and I got to talk to Vera no crowd a lot
so Bernard and crowd and David Wilson
came up with a lovely markov chain so
what's wrong with this Markov chain and
in fact metropolis a towel by the way
there's a little story about how i'ma
drop we shouldn't call it metropolis at
all because apparently all metropolis
did was get the grant or something uh so
it wastes a lot of time once you're
anywhere near the critical density Oh
try to move a disk there you can't do
nothing now I try to move it over there
you can't do nothing waste an enormous
amount of time so um a burner krauth and
Wilson came up with a markov chain which
doesn't waste any time it's rejection
free so what you do is you decide by
golly i am going to achieve a certain
displacement
a certain distance in a certain
direction I grabbed a disc I move it
until it bumps into another one I take
that displacement off the what I'm
trying to achieve I move the next one
until it bumps into something else and
so on until this total vector is my
original target um and in fact they find
that numerically they can do even better
with an irreversible version the other
thing we need to get away from is this
nonsense of reversibility so
irreversible things are the hot hot
stuff in physics right now so they find
they can do very well by just having two
different directions they try to move in
and naughty and not ever doing the
reverse direction um so in my dreams we
can analyze this Markov chain and show
that it's even that it's much faster
than the single disc dynamics and show
that we can get all the way up to the
transition this is in my dreams um maybe
using these something like these tower
moves for rhombus tilings from Looby
randall and Sinclair I know it these are
good dreams and you know because how
does that Markov chain work well I want
to put a rhombus here I can't but I
could if I put another one there I can't
do that so I just moved this whole tower
and they got this nice polynomial mixing
time results for rhombus tilings as long
as you choose a clever distribution of
the size of towers you want to try to
flip so as with Swenson Wang right the
challenge is it's very hard to make
coupling arguments work for chains which
change a lot of things at once and yet
these are the chains which seem to be by
far the most successful in in physics so
they're an important challenge for us
Eric will change they know the
stationary distribution is the same yeah
alright thank you very much yeah obvious
question of obey them half left thumb
have you Dean how can I put this
delicately brave enough to do the
geometry in three dimensions oh yeah we
haven't and I think that as you went up
to higher dimensions on the stuff that
we're doing would help less and less so
in particular okay so Cannon Mountain a
kanima honey and Montenegro um you know
they're the same argument shows that row
is at least one over two to the D minus
1 and D dimensions I don't think that
our arguments is are going to change
that asymptotics for large d it would
make some some very tiny difference for
three and I forget what the physics
belief is about how the critical row
scales I it I mean it scales I think
exponentially but with a different
constant being raised to the D I think
that's the belief I don't recall
so the danger zone seem to be very large
would you gain anything by somehow
softening the edges of the danger zone
so you say that it's kind of a little
bit bad if they only over like a little
bit and very bad if they overlap a lot
with that help with them not sure what I
mean the disks can't overlap at all
right they're just they're hard disks so
I think what you're doing is you're
saying you're a little bit worried about
a configuration where you've got two
disks to Center the closer than 400
right so that that's a binary decision
are you worried about this there this
will not I'm maybe I'm misinterpreting I
mean it's more like we know the
situation is much better than it is
because we know that the union of the
danger zones has a total size much less
than four are they cut you know so in
other words we're pessimistically
imagining right right because what do we
want we want to improve the probability
of a good move but probably of a good
move is the fraction of the world left
over after you remove all the danger
zones we're pessimistically assuming the
danger zones don't overlap so if given
of the danger zones overlap there's
actually a lot more room left over for
good moves than in our analysis but we
don't know how to make that rigorous
because it's a path coupling argument
and it would not be enough to say the
end point of the path is a typical state
okay so
okay one more question I think they were
just going right back to the beginning
so said you said that there couldn't be
a face where the correlations don't
decay that'll wake you up to this
infinite range this is this peerless
argument yeah so obviously the lattice
baseball of you can but there's
something special about continuous way
yes and um it's it's a classic argument
which I would have to look on wikipedia
before I could really reproduce it for
you but and it's and it's particular to
two dimensions so you know in one
dimension of course with any nonzero
temperature what things have to decay
exponentially and two dimensions they
have to decay polynomial e if things are
continuous and it's you know they're
just not enough paths to get information
far away in two dimensions so in three
or more dimensions you can have the
correlations go to a constant so kind of
the the slogan is that you can't really
have crystals in two dimensions but you
can in three or more so that's a
structure yeah yeah
okay well I think next time is pressing
on